Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with James Under Down, who's executive director
for the Center for Inquiry West in Los Angeles,
and the chair and founder of the Center for
Inquiry Investigations Group.
He's also the host of the upcoming web series
Skepta Lab.
The bunk stops here.
James, really great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, my pleasure.
Thanks for having me on.
Speaker 1: So one of the things that your
organization has done is you have offered
money, $500,000 for definitive proof of superpowers
or of a supernatural ability.
And the money continues to be available.
It's never it's never been collected on.
So let's first to understand what are the
parameters of the offer.
Speaker 2: Well, yeah.
The offer is half a million dollars for anyone
who can prove paranormal ability under scientific
test conditions.
And that means that you can't just call us
up and say you shot a video of something weird
happening.
Send me a check.
Or just take it on their word alone.
You have to be able to show up, show up in
person, and control conditions mean that we're
going to make sure to the best of our ability
that you're not cheating or using some ulterior
means to achieve whatever effect you're talking
about.
Speaker 1: Okay.
How many?
Let's go through the funnel.
How many people have gone through the proper
process of applying?
Speaker 2: Well, we average a couple of years
ago, we had over 250 applications.
We average between one and 200 applications
a year.
And usually it does whittled down when people
find out what they're going to have to do.
I think it self eliminates the people who
are planning to cheat.
Okay.
So and in fact, as long as I'm on that subject,
no one has ever tried to cheat during a test.
Anyone who shows up actually believes that
they have these superpowers.
So but the but it goes from so goes from 100,
200 to 200 a year applying.
And we only test like probably half a dozen
by the time all is said and done.
And everybody understands each other.
The negotiations, we figure out what the test
is going to be, what they say they can do,
what we're comfortable with, and then we're
off to the races.
Speaker 1: So the fact that people don't try
to cheat suggests that these are true believers.
They genuinely believe they have whatever
power they claim to have.
Speaker 2: Absolutely.
So far, 100% of 100% of them.
Now, of course, we do plan for people cheating,
so we retreat everyone, as if, you know, we
would close off these avenues of cheating.
But yeah, everyone who shows up thinks they're
going to succeed and get a lot of them are
really sort of surprised that, you know, they
can't defy millions to one odds and their
telepathic ability.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So let's talk about that when they fail.
Give us a sense of some of the reactions.
Does anybody say, hey, you know what, I actually
can't do this thing?
Or do people blame the test conditions?
Do they say it was an off day?
Speaker 2: Yeah, there is.
I mean, I, I keep saying I'm going to start
this the big book of excuses.
Yeah, well, a lot of them say, you know, too
much skeptic energy in the room, right?
Some of them say, oh, this test wasn't fair
even though they agreed to it, you know, 5
minutes earlier.
Some of them, it takes a few days for them
to to say that they were cheated or somehow
wronged, you know, So it varies there.
And let's see.
So we've been testing people at this point
for 23 years, and there are probably been
two or three who have come back and said,
you know, maybe I need to rethink this a little
bit and reconsider what's going on.
Speaker 1: What sorts of claims have you tested?
Are there types that are the most common ones?
Speaker 2: Yeah, probably the most common
test we do is telepathy.
So this is people thinking that they can project
their thoughts into someone else's mind.
That's most common.
Some people think that they can receive thoughts.
Lately, we've been getting a lot of people
who say they can use telekinesis as a big
one.
So the ability to move something with your
mind without touching it physically or anything.
So a lot of people about signing on claims
about moving clouds or doing things to the
sky.
Dozers.
We've tested a couple of dozers, some healers.
It's really all over the map.
Some people I mean, we've had people say that
they could create a rainstorm in the middle
of a desert.
Speaker 1: So like for that one, do you go
out to the middle of the desert?
Speaker 2: Well, what we in these sort of
predictive sort of claims, we make it very
clear that, look, you know, this can't be
in the Amazon jungle.
It can't be on an island in Hawaii.
It's got to be somewhere that doesn't have
rain very often.
You have to predict the exact time and the
exact place that this is going to happen.
So we closed these windows down.
So it's not just of chance occurrence of something
that would happen anyway.
Speaker 1: Right.
How do you deal with it?
I'm guessing, although you can tell me if
my assumption is wrong, that sometimes people
who are struggling with mental health issues
come to you and say, I can do this, that or
the other thing.
How how does that happen?
How do you deal with that?
Speaker 2: It actually happens fairly commonly,
especially with the telepaths.
So if you're experiencing voices in your head,
you're seeing some hallucination or you're
convinced that everyone can hear your thoughts
or that you know, you can hear their thoughts.
Those are symptoms from the DSM, the diagnostic,
all statistical manual from the mental health
world.
Yeah.
Those are known conditions and symptoms.
So, you know, we we try to gently suggest
to people what you're experiencing is consistent
with some forms of mental illness.
Please consider that that may be what's going
on here.
We'll test you anyway.
Yeah, but know that this is probably what's
happening.
And by the way.
This isn't just me.
Some blame and saying this.
We have three psychologists on our team and
a psychiatrist, so they're all in full agreement
that these are common symptoms that people
suffering from mental illness sometimes experience.
Speaker 1: When people come in.
There are there are instances of this sort
of thing where the people who assert these
abilities will say that they are, by their
nature, not really testable in this way.
Now, of course, the problem for organizations
like yours is that well then, then we're dealing
in an unforeseen fiable type of claim.
It's I'm asserting this, and it's not even
the type of claim you can evaluate.
What do you get some of those?
And then are you just not able to move forward
in that case?
Speaker 2: Yeah, so it could be.
Some people say that, you know, this just
happens every once in a while and I can't
put my finger on it.
I say when we say, look, we're not going to
follow you around 24 hours a day.
Right.
You have to be able to do this sort of on
demand.
So, yeah, it's just by the nature of it, we're
not going to fly to you in Istanbul and, you
know, spend six weeks with you.
All this wraps up again.
So and by the way, we do we test people from
all over the world.
Just the other day, we tested a guy who was
in Spain who said he could hypnotize us into
making us roll our eyes up into our heads,
you know, like you're going into a coma or
something.
Yeah.
So some of these things can be tested via
Zoom or Skype or whatever, and we're willing
to do that.
If it is, the test lends itself to that.
Speaker 1: That's convenient.
So you don't have to necessarily fly around
to then have your eyes not roll up into the
back of your head.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that could be dangerous if
you're on the road.
Speaker 1: So the new show, Skeptic Lab, The
Buck Stops here.
It debuts in just a couple of days, I believe,
with three episodes on telekinesis, astrology
and telepathy.
Speaker 2: Yeah, we started shooting this
web series.
You know, we've been doing this.
My group, the Center for Queer Investigations
Group, has been doing this for 23 years now,
since 2000.
And, you know, we just decided to we have
these scads of experiences with these people
and the benefit of decades of information
from the Committee for Skeptical Inquiry,
Skeptical Inquirer magazine, all these people
that we work with and are a part of, we thought,
why not try to get some of this debunking
information out there?
We actually got a little bit of a grant to
help us out with getting it produced.
And I know some people here in Hollywood who
are mostly on our side in terms of getting
science education out to the public.
So, you know, we got some of these celebrities
to help out and they're funny.
And so we get the information out there with
a little bit of humor and then bring in some
experts, too, to add to the mix and really
try to convince people that the stuff isn't
what it seems to be.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I love this stuff, so I'm
really looking forward to it.
Astrology in particular is interesting because
with a lot of that that's about personality
traits and vague horoscopes and these kind
of Barnum type statements.
What how do you debunk that?
Speaker 2: Yeah, some of the things are a
little tricky.
Astrology was kind of fun.
We had the help of Julia Sweeney, who was
a star on Saturday Night Live a while back,
and one of the things we did was we went out
to Hollywood Boulevard and sat up at the table
and said, Free astrology readings.
And we put all of the star signs and little
bins in front, and people came up and got
their reading and read it on camera.
Then they scored the reading and said, You
know, how well did we do?
I'm describing you the Libra that pretends
to describe, and they're giving it nines and
tens out of ten.
And then we'd say, okay, now pick up an heiress.
And it's the exact same astrology, right?
Our star rating.
So what does that tell you?
And a lot of them admitted right on the spot,
you know, that you could write something that
applies to just about everybody.
And it really isn't predictive at all.
It's just a general statement well written
toward that end.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And what's interesting about that is, in some
sense, you could say that doesn't really debunk
it, because if you just write a statement
that applies to most people, everybody would
accept that.
I guess there would be another way to test
it, which would be with different statements
and kind of like randomizing them and controlling.
You know, you could do a more complex test,
too, I'm sure.
Speaker 2: Right, Right.
You could you could set up you could get 12
people together and say, okay, talk to them
a little bit and pick out which one is the
Sagittarius.
Right.
You know, based on your discussion.
But we added one other thing to this discussion
and and this is what we try to do on Skeptic
Lab is we got Phil play too, as a working
astronomer.
And we said, you know, look, talk about these
these constellations out there which are meant
to be the driving force behind astrology talk
about, you know, the influence, the physical
influence they have on earth and Phil Watt
and talked about how far they are, the fact
that just because it might look like a crab
up in the sky doesn't mean the stars are anywhere
near each other, too.
They're not the same distance or anything.
He talked about the gravitational pull of,
you know, like a boss going by who has as
a bigger gravitational pull than, you know,
some star light years away.
So there's a lot of other there's multiple
ways to think of why astrology is is not real.
Speaker 1: Do you get into not so much more
in the direction of some of the medical stuff,
like, for example, you know, acupuncture is
one that's been looked at extensively.
And it seems as though in most tests, so-called
sham acupuncture works as well as, quote,
real acupuncture, the idea being that the
process of having someone listen to your symptoms
and then maybe the endorphin release from
the from the needles, no matter where you
place them does have an effect.
But it's no different with real versus do
you get into that stuff at all?
Speaker 2: We do.
You know, we're not.
My group isn't involved in that sort of research
per say.
But yeah, you're right.
I mean, there are aspects of a lot of the
faith healing kind of stuff and the alternative
medicine sort of stuff that is, you know,
the power of suggestion, the placebo effect
have a great deal to do with people feeling
better.
Now we do test healers.
And in fact, just a month or two ago, we had
a guy come in to test for the half million
dollars who said he could heal a lipoma on
one of our guys neck had a little lipoma on
there.
So we measured it and we got all these cameras,
you know, watching it Ozzy's as he's doing
it and he couldn't do it.
So, you know, if you can, if your claim is
that you can heal it on the spot and have
visual incontrovertible evidence right now
that it's healed, that's fine.
But, you know, you get these you get like
Benny Hannan, these televangelist healers
who say they're making they're healing people
and we just punch a lot of holes.
And why that's not really happening.
Speaker 1: What happens to all the video footage
of these failed tests?
Speaker 2: You know, we're getting better
at since we got the cameras for Skepta lab.
We're trying to get a little bit better.
We are.
We do shoot a lot most of this stuff, but
I don't know how to edit or anything, so it's
sort of being stored right now and we're using
some of it for the Scott the lab.
Okay.
And we'll use it in the future as well.
Speaker 1: I hope it's it's fascinating stuff.
So if there's someone in the audience, there
is a $500,000 reward available to you and
you can find out more by looking into the
center for inquiry.
We've been speaking with James under down.
The upcoming web series debuting in just a
couple of days is Skeptic Lab.
The Buck Stops Here.
James, really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 2: Thanks for having me on, David.
It's been a pleasure.